you
okay let's give this a go I'm gonna try
a couple games against computer
impossible so and it's the time controls
are five five two so there won't be any
crazy time scrambles hopefully not at
least so let's just go with what I've
played this line many times against it
and I've had some success so let's see
if I could do that while doing some
commentary so okay
the the only the only concern I had was
a quick c4 with Queen here but I should
be in time to meet this move now so II
six if Queen b3 I could play Queen b6
and if c5 well I can always come back to
c7 maybe capture but let's just do this
first I want to be in a spot to capture
like this if C takes D and I think it's
best to get this nut here first for time
reasons with this Queen b3 move Queen b6
if then c5 I could take capture play a
six and then meet the move b4 by moving
the rook off of the a file but we're not
going down that line or maybe we still
could maybe maybe clean here I'll still
be played okay so that captures so so
far so good
and hmm just where to go with the bishop
either d6 or eise Evan I think both
might be good eleven let me let me go to
d6 to keep control over this e5 square
this is a move I have to be concerned
about sure enough it's being played I
need to take Knight takes I take here
and am I going to be in some trouble
actually let me see let me take here
first and then I was wondering if I'm
gonna be in trouble after castles is
there Bishop takes h7 I don't think
that's working and I actually I think
I've played this very line before again
now while recording but I think I've had
this position before where there was an
isolated pond so my cannon moves our
castles Knight f6 I don't want to play
Bishop here cuz it cuz of capture and
then I'm in check it'll be uncomfortable
hmm Castle let me just make sure there's
no Bishop takes castle Bishop takes
takes with the King if then Knight g5 I
could take and if Bishop takes I take
their Queen so I think I could castle
and I probably should do that let me
castle did I miss calculate if you see
this move I miscalculated okay so this
should be perfectly fine now because in
an ideal world with this isolated pawn
you'd really like to remove the bishop
that could control that square so in
this case the light square bishop so if
this move isn't played right now I'm
gonna be able to blockade it so I could
block hate it and the only concern I
have is how do I do just that Knight b6
to d5 or Knight f6 to d5 I want to make
sure I could definitely get a piece
there if I go here I could get into a
pin it's not so inconvenient because I
could always move and if captures that
this is a fine pawn structure to have
doubled F ponds in the g6 pawn but I
think just to keep it super simple pivot
on b6 and then hop into here you know I
know I have control over this position
and there's no neither side has a lead
in development I think just Queen here I
do have some concern of Knight e5 but I
have that covered the bishop so just
bump up the Queen to e8 okay where's
this Knight going huh
let me see oh you know what I could do I
could get rid of this Knight oh maybe I
could play a position with a strong
night on this d5 square that cannot be
challenged that cannot be challenged so
Bishop to b4 pins the knight there might
have there might be some timely in
between those with
rook here maybe Bishop here a three
takes could this move be played mmm
maybe am I just seeing things
let's see Bishop b4 a3 I just take the
knight know if rook here I could take
the bishop I'd get I've broken two minor
pieces so I'm gonna try for this just to
get rid of that pesky night so I could
rely upon this d5 square where my knight
goes unchallenged so now he just it's
best to just get him here and I just
want to trade trade some more so let's
get rid of this rook mm-hmm or maybe not
so fast rook here I think it's just
gonna double and I want to be able to
kick it off that I'm not really too big
of a fan of capturing here and having
this structural change or this it's no
longer gonna be an isolated pawn would
be a group of four pawns together um
it's a good thing I have increment here
down to less than a minute but uh I
think maybe f6 first and then when the
rook moves I play king f7 and then I
could go forward with a bunch of trick a
bunch of trades on the e-file so I think
this is one of the last important
moments of the game that I'm gonna have
to start rattling off moves let's let's
go for this f6 first and then King here
if Brooke here I could play Queen f5
okay oh that's a sneaky move okay well I
better get rolling here
34 seconds I can always do this oh
that's a pain that's a definite pain I
am officially in a pin yeah actually
just double keep keep everything really
solid just get my rook here and my other
rook here okay I have I still control I
might want to do this see it's got
nothing it really it really has nothing
let me just do this I don't want a week
in my c6 pawn hmm can't do this I'd be
dropping my rook at the
then maybe maybe maybe I should finally
put a question this rook I give up this
square I'm really weakening my dark
squares I I just want to kind of sit and
I don't I don't see a way to improve my
position oh boy
I'm in trouble
I'm in big trouble timewise and
everything yeah I'm gonna get mated
right here
oh man that fade I'm dead on time and
position man snuck right in
why didn't I even consider just taking
that bishop that was a bad way to end I
had I felt like I had so much control
but that rook it wasn't so quick to uh
to give up a piece right without
allowing a structural change alright
let's let's give it one more shot
I should I felt like I should have done
so much better I got what I wanted that
night on d5 but it was it was being a
pest let's try one more yeah I was it
was gonna be look at this I've had to
play this against me before too and I
had a good position and I don't know how
I don't think it'd turn out so well okay
so what did I do the last time it did
something crazy like this okay it
weakens h5 + f5 h5 in particular and I
think a knight moved to E to G 3 and h5
could turn out to be quite good and I'd
really like to have the position closed
up maybe if this pawn goes two squares
this could be a really nice square to
hop into however as a start I think you
really can't go wrong with deploying the
Queen 9 so let's let's get rolling with
that first and what more do I want to
play I think I want to play my pawn up
here yeah let's do that I'm threatening
this so something needs to be done
alright and I don't know that I want to
do this move mmm III or Eve for what's
wrong which is grabbing some center
space
this is clearly wasted some time let me
grab some space d4 is gonna have some
fire placed under it
hmm Bishop III nightie 2 G 3 H 5 does
the order really matter Bishop e3 Bishop
g2 night e 2 G 3 H 5 that's really what
I want to do hmm let me let me develop
my bishop I'm not yet gonna declare my
Knights intentions ok this is a very
passive move very passive so now I think
I could go for my little journey 92 g3
h5 ok I knew that was gonna be played so
I want to stop night here and I could do
that
just Knight g3 no no you can still play
there the bishops watching over so h3 or
F thread definitely want to stop the
knife from playing here and which one
should I move maybe a guy with age three
age three and then night here okay age
three which one's better h3 or f3 I
really don't know um no no no no I dunno
I'm gonna go with age three but because
I want to keep this dog and I'll open I
want my queen to have direct sight of
this square so I have just that finally
get my night out of the way and now get
my Bishop to e2 okay I'm very happy with
this position so far so far
there should be two I have control over
this position in its weakened this
square okay I think I know what I want
to do now I want to grab some space I
want to focus on this square can you
hear it in my voice I'm getting a little
a little excited here I think I might
have the possibility of winning this one
because I have a space advantage and
these are very weak f5 and age five in
an ideal world I want these guys off the
board I want to have g4 in and throw my
knight on f5 how could I manage that
if I play Knight here takes and then f5
I don't want this pawn advance to be
played so hmm Bishop here I could do
that Knight takes pawn takes and then I
get my knight here I think I'm gonna do
that let's just roll with it Queen here
oh my goodness
are you kidding me ah man I totally
missed that it should still be alright
though right I still I still work with
this they have to give the piece back
okay stay focused here oh you know it
could do f5 and then f4 and it has its
pick oh my goodness
that was a that was a killer ah man
should have seen that okay let's work
with it here um Bishop yeah I got I have
to take the knight so I'm gonna take
jeez I don't even know how to take which
way do you take I I guess I'll go like
this woo okay alright and let's just go
back so yeah take the bishop are you
gonna play here alright so the material
is still the same it's still balanced
played this and then 94 just get 94 in
right at right now I should probably do
this right away and that's gonna play
here he's gonna be a tough guy he is
definitely gonna be very very tough oh
man maybe I should move this night so I
could give this Knight a kick with the
g3 that's gonna be tough though however
you slice it it's gonna be very tough
hmm 35 seconds is not a lot okay let's
just see how this thing is gonna punish
me
I feel the punishment is gonna happen
very soon very soon I should keep him
out right
this is weak now I want to be able to
play f3 let's stop there b5 stuff Castle
f3 I don't like taking my rook off the H
file but you have to work with it I
guess
ah it's got nothing nothing there
I have light-square control let's just
keep everything nice and cozy there's
gonna be a trick here there is oh my
goodness can I hold this though
maybe it's miscalculated maybe it
doesn't understand this position as well
as I do that's not the case though is it
that's not the case can I keep control
over this
I have light-square control that was
that was a bad joke by the way a very
bad joke I didn't mean that yeah this is
done this is done I play rook here night
here I got to defend like this there's
maybe b5 happening soon no really
all right 7 seconds I hold this it's all
my night in here tricky stuff here
that's running it's scared
it has a lot of fear ah ok I have a
decent blockade I think keep this pocket
7 seconds I have some control over this
actually have some control over this
position I guess to anticipate this move
maybe get my knight back here get my
king up he needs to defend stuff control
this oh boy I could I could deal with
that Bishop been given discovered check
I'll keep my rook here defend that I
think I just keep my rook sitting here
you can't enter cannon ah let's just
play here can I can I hold this light
square control light square control yeah
it's just trying to time burn but this
is uh this is what
I got that increment I should be able to
hold this the only break is c6 and
that's gonna happen I need to I need to
buy some time here I don't want to allow
this advance that's right I'm cooking my
rook here so I think I just need to go
back and forth it might make it might
play like 49 moves and then finally do
this that's probably what's gonna happen
hmm then I'm gonna be in trouble then
I'm definitely gonna be in trouble so I
better Bank sometime and then put
pressure on this as soon as that break
comes draw fir
it's never gonna it declines it declines
I knew that was gonna happen 24 seconds
see these were I wasn't so good those
Moza was doing so this bishop is kind of
a dead piece isn't it gotta get my King
back he needs to watch over these two 28
seconds getting some time I don't know
how many moves it's been so far I need
to stay focused g4 needs to be covered
my rook needs to stay here back and
forth we go eventually it's gonna make
progress here we go the Kings may be
taking a hike over towards the Queen
side keep my king it's very easy to lose
focus I could see myself moving here and
then forgetting g4 don't let that happen
note to self
watch over g4 and efore unless you're in
check that's the rule of thumb I'm gonna
follow it's gonna be a draw come on
you're gonna play here or not I'm in
check I got to get out of that so I've
banked some time get back here I was
attacked back and forth we go move 76 I
don't know what move it's gonna need to
be in order for it to be that repetition
but I doubt it's gonna happen I imagine
c6 is gonna happen I could actually
still not fear the bishop move the
discovered check is no biggie
and no here we go
here we go c6 happening
see six happening even if something oh
now this is definitely a draw or is it
huh
change of structure so c6 was my biggest
concern now the next biggest concern is
this and then and this and then this
move let's do this though is it maybe
it's gonna be content with the draw at
this point what it really sacrificed
this stuff stay here I still I need to
watch over that I have to keep this I
don't want my king to be dislodged back
and forth we go wow we're gonna set a
record maybe now there's been much
longer games especially with increment
but you just stay here I need to keep
control light-square controls the name
of the game here this is lovely a lot of
thinking is going into Rick h1 h2 okay
when's that break gonna be I'm in check
it out of it
keep that knight on e4 he's a monster
isn't he controlling that he's a top on
top on syndrome right here he's seven
back and forth
when's that next draw I don't even I
just want to keep going back and forth
here back and forth there's this move
oops
what'd I just do I didn't do anything
okay I want to stay on these two notice
I'm never playing the h3 I want to have
the opportunity to swing over to this
side of the board if need be if we're
gonna have this move and we may have
that it might try to I've seen it do
that I've seen it mistakenly try to go
for more and then maybe I could come
back and actually win when this is
clearly a drama position but can I keep
it a draw that's the big question 31
seconds and moved 105 let's go rook h1
h2 how is it gonna make progress
does anybody know I don't know I don't
know
that's all I'm seeing is b5 eventually
this bishop gonna weasel around I'm in
check let's get out of it if I could get
back here I'm getting back here
very basic very basic I think keep going
move 114 okay I think I can I think I
can all right should I have for a DRA
soon is there gonna be a pawn break
we're gonna see this game is gonna end
very soon I think
119 get back here all right
rook h1 h2 get back
rook h1 h2 keep my king there I was just
ready to go back here to eat you I'm
gonna end up screaming if that happens
like to cut by mistake you know what
there might be h5 then I know for sure
it's a draw then I know for sure there's
no tricks here as it covered move 128
repetition happening soon it's got to be
130 130 moves 51 seconds have been
banked and now this is where there might
be some pawn push I don't believe it oh
it might happen oh no it's gonna happen
oh there it is should I have stopped
that too late now ah man can I is there
still some sort of a fortress is it
pushing its luck if I take here I can't
lose my center pond if I go here it's
gonna take one and oh man take towards
the center let's have a good reason not
to I just I don't maybe I have a good
reason not to but I can't think of I
can't think look here look here and
allow that Queen to have some entry
squares let's try here it's a passed
pawn now oh boy eight point two seconds
oh it's just it got out of the check and
now there's that move
ah gotta get that pun I win this oh boy
here oh there's gonna be that pond push
there it is tricky pawn push oh this is
crumbling now it's definitely crumbling
it's still hold a ball no not really
quick we check here oh this is brutal
night here here comes the checks here
comes the pain here it is oh I am dead I
can't deal with that
ah man that was a marathon 142 moves
that b5 movement must have just came I
should have offered a job maybe it
wasn't the 15 moves just yet but ah look
at the progress it made that's the one
fear I had the b5 advance and I should I
have come over as soon as the Queen was
facilitating a four should I have come
over here I was fearful of this break
though as soon as that would have
happened ah I don't know what do you
think was it actually ol double or not
feel free to leave some feedback what a
monster okay that's all for this video
feel free to again yeah leave some
comments if you'd like take care bye
you